um welcome and good evening everyone my
name is
nan one of the uh volunteers of the buy
data jitter chapter
uh i'm here with my oh my
team members yasmin and hassan shaddad
and
today's meetup is titled transformers
from the ground up by dr sebastian
rashka dr sebastian is an assistant
professor of statistics
at the wisconsin at the university of
wisconsin medicine
focusing on deep learning and machine
learning research
uh he's also a contributor to open
source software and the author of the
best-selling book
python machine learning uh thank you dr
sebastian for joining us
and also we want to thank our sponsors
random focus
and mozun um if you want to visit
our paid by data website
or follow the twitter account to be
updated about
our new upcoming meetups and we also
post
a lot of cool things on there
and i guess that's all from me i'll stop
sharing so dr sebastian can start
thank you yes thank you so much for the
kind introduction i really appreciate it
it's my pleasure to be here
thanks for the invitation so i will um
start then by
sharing my screen and if there's some
issue please let me know
um i can then try to fix that so it
should be
visible now can you see everything
yes it's clear yeah oh perfect great
okay yeah then yeah we'll get started so
today
the talk is about transformers the
natural language processing
models in deep learning and i'm trying
to yeah cover
transformers from the ground up like
explaining a little bit how they work
and then also i hope we have time for
that at the end showing you an
implementation in pytorch
so yeah why this topic so um yeah i
personally got very interested in this
topic recently and i was also working on
the new edition for my python machine
learning book and was just putting
together the chapter
and had this very long lecture at my end
of the semester last um
last semester when i was teaching the
deep learning class and this is
essentially more like
um yeah a condensed version of that
highlighting the main concepts by
skipping over the mathematical details
which i think would take too much time
to digest it would be more like a
week-long
effort to dig through all the details
but i hope this will give you like a
good idea of how transformers work
and also helping you like navigating the
jungle of all the terminology a little
bit because there's so many different
models out there like
bird gpt version one gpt version two and
um yeah you might wonder how they are
different and what you can do with
transformers
so yeah just to start a few examples
where transformers are
used nowadays so one popular example
would be language translation that is
also
um how the original transformer
architecture was developed
so language translation was the main
motivation behind developing the
original architecture
and yeah nowadays transformers are
pretty much everywhere when it comes to
natural language processing
and even beyond that there are many yeah
real world applications of transformers
for example
um recently i also saw this article so
i'm also working in computational
biology problems
recently there was this article on on
using transformers to
kind of elucidate or decipher properties
and proteins like
organizing proteins by structure
properties but also by function
and they train for instance transformers
on a large scale of
um a large-scale database of amino acid
sequences like protein sequences and
they
found all kinds of interesting insights
from that
and yeah you probably have seen recently
the github
copilot project i think this was in um
collaboration with openai and i think
also microsoft
where they um trained a transformer to
generate code
so here what is interesting is that you
can essentially um
enter a query a comment a code comment
and this
um yeah ai system the model will
generate the corresponding code here at
the bottom
so if you go to this website they have
like a nice animation of how that works
and they have a
microsoft or what is a visual studio
code plugin where you can yeah download
this and actually use that in action
which is um yeah really
impressive so i think right now they
have um javascript support and python
support
so that would be another interesting
application of transformers
so transformers mainly are about uh
generating
things like generating translations or
generating code
generating text for instance also in
chatbots but you can also use them for
classification like
classifying or let's say whether a movie
review is positive or negative
and this will be a code example we will
be covering at the end of this lecture
or talk um so the topics i have
in mind for today are those so first i
wanted to
from the historic perspective just
briefly explain
how attention came to be so there was
essentially this um
attention mechanism that was first added
to recurrent neural networks
and then there was this self-attention
mechanism which is a
i would say a more sophisticated version
of that there's this
so-called scaled dot product attention
oops i almost ripped off my microphone
here
yeah so and then we will talk about the
original
transformer architecture which is the
first architecture that was just using
attention
so in step one here this is a recurrent
network augmented with attention and the
transformer is then an architecture is
just using attention
without any recurrent neural network
layers and then i will briefly
dive into some of these large scale
language models for example
yeah gpt and bird which are pretty
popular these days
and then after that we will pre-train or
sorry we will fine-tune a pre-trained
bird model in pyth
so one thing about these uh large scale
language models is that they are
really large scale and would take
forever to train them
so in practice usually they are trained
on large
data sets thousands or millions of
yeah websites and books and so forth and
so usually people download a pre-trained
version
and then fine-tune it to a target task
so we'll also take a look at how
yeah that looks like and then i have a
few closing
thoughts or words on transformers and
yeah with that i think
we have plenty of things to talk about
in the next um
i would say 40 minutes so to get started
with
um the attention mechanism that was so
first a
small disclaimer here so like i
mentioned in the beginning so this will
be more like a conceptual overview so if
there are some
let's say notational details in these
figures don't worry about them too much
um to be honest i think it's most
important to kind of understand the big
picture and all the mathematical details
that is something that uh almost like
implementation details some of them are
almost arbitrary
so i wouldn't worry about it too much
but i hope this talk kind of peaks your
interest
in terms of transformers so if you're
interested in that you can
yeah dive in deeper into the topic
afterwards with having this
big picture overview in mind so
starting with the first topic augmenting
the recurrent neural networks with
attention
so first what is the motivation behind
using attention why don't we just use
recurrent neural networks
so if you think of a task a
sequence to sequence task which is a
task where you have an input sequence
and you want to generate an output
sequence
one common example of that would be a
language translation
where you have an input sequence let's
say this one here in blue
in a one language let's say german
and you want to translate this into
english so
um here on the output then you have an
output sequence
and what happens is if you use a or if
you design an arc
architecture for that you usually use
this encoder decoder setup
in rnns so that means that the rnn
first ingests the whole input sequence
so you have input element one
two and three so these are for instance
individual works
and they are then processed into these
hidden states and once you have
processed the whole input in this
encoder so this would be essentially the
encoder part you have all the
information in one
one hidden state here and then you have
the decoder part
which here generates the output so one
might wonder
why don't you um yeah why don't you
translate this
one by one because here one problem
would be that this hidden state has to
remember all the input
in in one hidden state and this might be
a little bit overwhelming
right so if you have one hidden state
that has to capture the whole input
there might be some information loss and
this is essentially one of the
challenges of these
rnns they work kind of well if you have
short sentences but the longer your
sentence becomes
the more challenging it is for the
network to generate a good output
because it kind of forgets
what happened let's say here in the very
beginning if you have a very very long
input sequence
so and also yeah why don't we just um
translate a
sentence word by word so here's um just
one example
um yeah because i only speak two
languages in german and
a little bit of english i have a german
to english translation example here
so it's just an attempt on translating
this german sentence here
at the top into an english sentence and
you can see
what happens if you translate this word
by word so it doesn't really work
so you have a sentence um i'm in english
as a second language speaker so
i'm usually also not that good at that
but i can tell
that this one is definitely wrong so you
can see here um the sentence is
can you help me can you me help this
sentence to translate it doesn't really
make sense if you
just let's say take a dictionary and
translate word by word
so to have a correct i hope this is
correct if you have a correct
english um translation the sentence
would be can you help me to translate
this sentence
and you can see there is some uh yeah
some
longer range dependencies there are some
words here for instance those
that you can just uh translate word by
word but then you have
let's say these two here where they are
kind of flipped so in order to translate
this word
the help you have to look into the
future basically so you have to find
an element that is further away in the
input sequence
or for example if you have this work
here it goes
here you can see there's a more longer
range dependency and the longer your
sentences are
the longer these dependencies become so
in that way
we can't really have this word by word
um
translation attempt because it would not
result in any meaningful
or grammatically wrong translation so
going back
this is why we first read the whole
input because yeah
we need to have knowledge about the
whole input before we can attempt the
translation but then again the challenge
is okay
we may forget earlier hidden states
so one idea to deal with this problem
that we
can capture these long range
dependencies is this attention mechanism
so this was first proposed
in the context of rnns in 2014
so i also i will share my slides so you
if you
are interested you can look up these
papers and read a little bit more
details about that so there was this
attention mechanism that the researchers
used to augment
the rnn to better get to better process
the input
so here's just like a sketch in the
lower left corner
for instance if we are thinking of the
second step here the hidden state
might have axis or at this step in
general you might have access to the
whole sequence
i used just different line widths to
denote that one
input sequence might be more important
than another and this is where the
attention comes
in so one step will have access to the
whole input
but with a waiting term that says okay
maybe
at this position this term is more
important than let's say this term and
so forth so not
every word is equally important so
there's also some some
sort of waiting and the architecture
looks approximately like that this is a
sketch i made after the paper
this is just a little bit different
notation but essentially what we have is
we have an
input sequence so this is just
individual works one two t
works and then they have uh two rnn's
kind of connected here so there's one r
n
it's a bi-directional rnn by direction
rn is just a fancy word for an rn that
processes the sequence from left to
right and from right to left
it's just so that it captures yeah
information from both ends
it's just um increasing the amount of
information you have essentially
so the forward direction would be the
regular r n direction
and then you essentially just flip the
sequence and process it backwards so
this would
be denoted here so you can denote it
from right to left but you can also
think of it
as just reversing the sentence and
processing it in the
regular way and then yeah you connect
these hidden states
and then you then you calculate the
so-called attention weights
i will skip over the details of how
these attention weights are computed
here
but i will show you how they are
computed in the transformer
it's a little bit different but not too
different so but the main part here is
really that
uh using these attention weights we
obtain the so-called context vector at
each
step so the context vector here is
essentially a weighted version of all
the inputs so you can consider
all the hidden states here and it's
essentially a weighted sum
you you have this attention weight you
multiply it by this
state and then you just sum them up and
the larger the tension weight yeah the
more
the hidden state will contribute to this
context vector so
this context vector is essentially then
kind of capturing all the input
information in a
certain processed way and this goes into
each
decoder part so if i go back a few
slides
um we had this decoder part here where
we were generating some output
and this is what we are having here at
the top the os they should just denote
let's say the translated sentence
and in each output step what we have is
we have the hidden state
that goes into let's say the
that position the previous word because
it's also important i mean
if you generate a sentence you kind of
look at the previous word you have just
written right so
what you currently translate the current
word is also depending on the previous
word you have written
otherwise yeah the sentence might not
make sense so you provide the
previous word you provide the hidden
state and you provide this context
vector and with that you can
capture all the input when you attempt
the translation of the next word
so this is essentially an enhanced
version of a recurrent
network for translation where this party
is essentially new that's the
attention part yeah and um
from this attention part people then
develop this
self-attention mechanism so the
self-attention mechanism is one major
building block of this
original transformer architecture that
we will cover and it's kind of inspired
by this rnn that i just showed you
so here's a very simple version of
self-attention it's not the version that
is actually used in the transformer
that comes in a future slide this is a
simplified version just to
understand the main concept so what you
can see here is
so to cover it step by step there are
three steps
and the first one is computing these dot
products
so imagine we are currently processing a
given word
x i and we compute the similarity of
this word
this is how we get a certain score for
computing the attention weights
you compute the similarity of this to
all the other words
including itself and why are so what
we have here is a sequence of words one
to t
and why are there four blocks there so
the four blocks
they just know that this is a vector so
it's for example a word embedding so
usually when we do natural language
processing
we don't really feed it in the string of
the word so we usually have a method
that converts the string let's say to a
vector of real numbers and this should
just denote a word embedding here
and then there's this um here this dot
product between two word embeddings
two vectors that we multiply and let's
say this gives us the attention weight
so it's just a simplified version
usually we would some use something like
a softmax function which is a function
that would normalize them
so that they sum up to one and from that
we then again um compute the weighted
sum
of these so we have these attention
weights and then we have our
vectors so vector one to t
and we just weight them by the
corresponding attention rates
i should say also we have um
a special a specific attention weight
for each
query so if um let's say
x i here is my query these attention
weights will be different
compared to if x2 is my query because it
depends
on the on the dot products right so
these would change
each word has different embedding so
every um
yeah every query has its unique
attention weights and from that we
derive this context vector which is kind
of similar what i've showed you uh in
the rnn example so this is a simple form
of self-attention where we just
introduce some
weighting of all the inputs when we
compute some output for a current word
so one problem with that though is so
the main takeaway here is that we
compute these attention rates but one
problem is that we don't have any
mechanism for
training a neural network now right
because there is no no
weight parameter involved so how do we
improve this how do we use let's say
back propagation or gradient descent
with that to
learn the optimal attention weights for
example so for that um
we in practice actually use a different
type of attention it's called
on scaled dot product attention it's one
form of self-attention
with learnable weights so this involves
weight parameters
and yeah there are then three matrices
and with these matrices
you compute uh also again like a vector
a query a key and a value
using the input query but here now these
matrices are weight parameters that you
can update during back propagation
or gradient descent to to optimize
the model so here
what's going on here is we have a
current input query that we are
currently processing let's say the
second word here again
and from the second word we apply these
three matrices
to um compute three values or three
vectors so a query a key and a value
and um using those so
so what we do then is we use the query
first so this this query
to compute these omega values these are
kind of like unscaled attention dates
with each key so the key is computed
for each input word again and we compute
the dot product between query and key
but notice
here we always use the query 2. which is
our current word that we are processing
so we again
obtain these unique values or unique
attention weights for each query that we
are currently processing
and then there are some normalization
steps so this is
dot product attention it's a soft max
with a scaling factor essentially
and then again like before we are
summing them up to this context vector z
so this is essentially the same that i
showed you here except that it now
involves
these trainable matrices and this is
yeah this is the basic um
building block behind these transformer
networks
so um yeah it's maybe a little bit fast
but to be honest there is
really not that much behind the
self-attention it
looks maybe a little bit complicated so
maybe you need to look at this a little
bit longer it took me definitely some
time um
to understand what's going on there to
be honest um a good way for me learning
about that was really like
reading the paper and then doing these
or making these figures and drawing that
to kind of make sense of it
um but yeah once once you take a look at
this it's actually not as complicated as
as it looked like it looks like i think
the complicated part here is more like
that these
language models are so large and if you
look at the code itself it's kind of
like overwhelming because there's so
many
um things going on there in in the code
not
not in the building block here so now to
get to the original transformer
architecture which is
built on this um self-attention
mechanism
so um this is based on this
paper attention is all you need that
started all the trends in terms of
developing transformers it's a very
influential paper that came out in 2017
it's not too long ago
four years ago and since then there have
been hundreds if not thousands of
different um transformer architectures
but yeah um the main part is essentially
that this is centered around this
self-attention mechanism
and it does not use any rnn parts so
there's no recurrent
uh neural network layer nothing it's
just i'm using
the self-attention concepts and i'm
stacking them
and then also having some fully
connected layers like in a multi-layer
perceptron just a very
basic neural network layers and here's a
sketch of how the transformer
architecture looks like
so yeah like i mentioned it it looks uh
very complicated at first glance there
are a lot of boxes and lots of things
connected to each other but essentially
it's um
again not too bad it's uh relatively
um straightforward it's actually again
our encoder
and decoder like in the rnn that i
showed you earlier where
the job of the encoder is to yeah ingest
this on
input sequence and the decoder job is to
generate
the output sequence and
yeah what you do first is you have a
word embedding for example to
embed the words into real valued vectors
there's something like a
positional encoding um because the
problem is um there's
its permutation invariant here but we
will skip over these details
it's just like a way of encoding the
position of the word
so um then we have this so-called
multi-head attention
it's an kind of like i would say an
extension of the self-attention
mechanism i will have a slide on that to
briefly explain what that is
then there is a layer normalization
and yeah like a multi-layer perceptron a
fully connected network
um and then again a layer normalization
and so forth
so it's um just repeating some of these
units and in between
we also have something like these arrows
you're connecting things
and these are skip connections um it's
essentially just um this is what the ad
stands for it's taking this value
and adds it back here it's similar to
what a residual network
um does if you have heard of a residual
network it's just like a means of
preventing let's say a bad gradient so
if you have something like a vanishing
gradient problem here
then this one
will be added to this one it's it's kind
of like skipping layers if the layers
are bad
then there's an opportunity to skip them
via these connections so to prevent
um yeah bad layers for uh from ruining
the whole network
and then yeah this encoder just captures
essentially the input
in this self-attention weighted way it's
like an encoding of the input
and this feeds into the decoder which
has itself also
multi-head attention there's a masked
version which i will also talk a lot a
bit about um
yeah and this is essentially it so it
goes again through a fully connected
network and then there's a fully
connected layer
to produce the outputs so the fully
connected layer is then
producing word probabilities with a
softmax function like
how likely is this word at a given
position and then
in practice we usually use the highest
probability if we
let's say do a language translation or
if we generate text in general
if we want to have some randomness we
want our model to generate different
texts
we could also just um sample from this
distribution
but yeah in the original transformer
architecture what they had in mind was
language translation yeah um to dive a
little bit more
into this multi-head attention it sounds
like it's a whole new concept
but it's essentially just our
self-attention mechanism so here this is
the scaled dot product attention that we
talked about earlier with these
different uh matrices
and um multi-head attention is just
repeating this multiple times it's
basically a stack
of these things it's kind of like
similar when you
you um if you have worked with
convolutional networks and you have
an input and you apply multiple kernels
to produce
multiple feature maps as the output it's
kind of like the same concept that each
channel
um captures different type of
information here so in that way this is
a similar concept where
you just repeat the self-attention
multiple times and stack it um
up to each other and this helps
extracting different features that are
useful and yeah one thing about that is
um
what's also nice is that here
when we have this stacking what the
advantage is
we can parallelize that because there's
no dependency between
these individual scale dot product
retentions so you can compute this in
parallel it
helps us also to leverage multiple gps
for example
and um yeah for that there are these
so-called heads tension heads
and each attention head has essentially
one set of these matrices so if we have
h um attention heads we have h sets of
these
matrices and then we just repeat the
same thing multiple times
and also i should say here this is um
six times so these blocks are also
repeated six times
i think this is what makes the
architecture so big and complicated when
you look at the code if you look at a
let's say from scratch implementation
it's just there are so many layers and
there's just so much
um code that implements all of that
but the underlying concepts if you draw
them out they are not
um itself themselves that are not that
complicated it's just
your matrix multiplication and then
softmax and matrix modification
i will talk a bit about this mask maybe
here so the masked
multihead attention is masking out words
that we haven't generated yet
so we have a target sequence that is our
let's say desired output um that we want
to generate let's say if we want to
translate something but at a given time
step we
don't want to have something that is in
the future so if we generate a sentence
let's say um
like let's say have a sentence help
we translate this
so first we would have then let's say a
german version of that but let's say
this is our
target version so in the first step
we would only have access to help and
then this one would be masked out
and then at the second step we would
have access to
these two words and these would be
masked out and the masked
multihead attention is essentially
ensuring that future words that are not
generated yet are
masked out
oh yeah i have actually a slide about
that yeah and this
masking out this can also be considered
as a unidirectional
form of language modeling because we are
masking out
everything that is in the future from
the current position so we are
masking out from left to right so it's
kind of um unidirectional
and we will also talk about a model that
has a so-called
bi-directional approach so the bird
model um
has a bi-directional approach and we
will revisit this topic it's
um kind of in it sounds actually fancier
than it is
so we will see in the future what this
um bi-directional means also
okay so yeah um this was already yeah
um all the transformer general original
transformer
stuff i wanted to talk about and these
were all the
original ideas like from a historic
perspective so
nowadays people don't use this original
transformer architecture anymore but
there are many many other architectures
that have been inspired by this
architecture so here in this section i
want to briefly highlight some of them
so one is this gpt model developed
mainly by the openi
team and this takes this unidirectional
approach which is
kind of similar to the decoder of the
original transformer
and this is used for tasks that involve
generating texts you can use it for
classification too but mainly the focus
is on yeah generating text
and then there is the bird model and of
course there are yet
other different types of versions of it
for example roberta and alberta and so
forth
but in general the bird model is a
bidirectional approach
and this is more suited or better suited
for
classification tasks for example in the
code example that i prepared where we
predict or
whether the movie review is positive or
negative
so whether someone liked the movie or
not
um yeah but one one scheme that is
common among amongst
most transformers is that there are two
steps one is a pre-training step a
pre-tearing step on very large
unable data sets and then there is a
fine-tuning step
where we take a pre-trained model and
then we
train it on our target data set so here
in step one
this is usually a general data set that
is not really related to our target task
it's for instance just a library of
books or websites
but we don't have any labels and yeah
this is just used to
to pre-train the model they are very
large models so they need a lot of data
to
um be kind of um yeah pre-trained
so and for this um training there are
these two steps that i mentioned the
pre-training and the fine tuning
one and two and the fine tuning can also
be
split into two different approaches and
both are very common um
i think fine tuning is a little bit more
common performs better but it's also
more expensive
so um one is yeah on this feature-based
approach and one is this fine-tuning
based approach
so how do they differ so assume you have
step one where you
pre-train your transformer so this is
sometimes called
in the original literature it's called
unsupervised pre-training
but the more modern term for that is um
self-supervised learning
so the same thing essentially where you
train a model on
unenabled data and then
so the data is unlabeled but it's still
a supervised learning approach
this is why it's called super
self-supervised learning
so you generate essentially the labels
um
yourself so you take let's say a book
and then you train the model
to predict you remove some words and
then you train the model to predict
missing words
or you predict the next word in the
sentence and the next word in the
sentence would be your label
but it's not like a label for
classification it's just like a label
that you can generate yourself from the
text you don't need to have a human
labeling these texts um
yeah so and then let's assume we have
now our pre-trained transformer
in this red block so then
once you have it pre-trained on a large
data set you never have to change it
again in terms of um
so you basically save that somewhere on
your computer and then you can use it
for all your downstream projects
is what i mean and one way is to never
really change it you take it and then
you just extract the last layer so you
give it a new sentence
and then you extract the output layers
one or more output layers you can
concatenate them
and then you give these output layers to
a classifier for example on logistic
regression multi-layer perceptron maybe
a random forest
whatever you desire and you only train
this classifier
so you essentially treat this
pre-trained transformer as a feature
extractor if you have used
something like principal component
analysis um this is also one method
let's say it's a linear transformation
of your input it's one method to let's
say
extract some features from your original
features so
it's in that way the pre-trained
transformer acts like a feature
extractor where you just use it to
extract these last layers
and then you just train a classifier on
top of that
another approach is this fine tuning
approach it's a little bit more
expensive
this is um you know for what i um
prepared this code example
so this fine tuning approach is a little
bit different in that you update the
whole model
so again you start with your pre-trained
transformer let's say you
saved it somewhere on your hard drive
you make a copy of that
and then you feed it the label training
data set that you have
and you um add a few layers for
classification
let's say if you have if we have our
movie review data set we
add one final node in the output layer
have a softmax activation
and then we just train the whole model
with um
so we update all the model parameters
and because um
we have to load all the models uh the
whole model in memory and
do the back propagation it's a little
bit more expensive than than this step
where we only use the transformer for
generating the features
so that way it depends it's of course
also slower
so it depends on what type of
architecture you have access to
to use this approach but in practice it
performs a little bit better
i think i forgot which paper it was
either gpt-1 or
bird they also directly compared those
approaches
i think might be gpd one but i would
have to double check
and they found i think if you lose use
the last three layers here
you can get approximately the same
performance as with fine tuning so
in that way it's it's really um you can
get the same performance but it's really
a trade-off also of
how much computation resources you have
um yeah so talking a bit about the gpt
models so there are
three gpt models now so one was released
in 2018
one in 2019 one in 2020 and yeah um if
the sequence continues we maybe have a
new version
by the end of this year and yeah one
obvious thing you can see from these gpt
models which
stands for generative pre-trained
transformer
is that yeah they increased a lot in
size so they started with 110 million
parameters which was already really huge
then the next one had 1.5 and now we
have 107
175 billion so who knows maybe the next
one
is in the trillion range so if you are
interested um
like i said i will share my slides later
so you can
also i'll read more about that in the
original manuscripts
but yet just to give you um just brief
summary of
how these models work i have a few
slides on those
so gpt one that's the first model in
this series
it's essentially very similar to the
transformer we talked about
especially i mean it's just taking the
decoder part
and um yeah it's trained on a sentence
in this next word prediction manner
so the pre-training is taking a large
context or a large corpus of books
or websites i think i think they used a
big a mix of
words from websites and books and they
have these sentences where
they remove through this masking the
future words and the model's task is to
predict the next word
and they just train the model in this
manner so they train it
just for this prediction of the next
word in the sentence
and after doing that you can then fine
tune it so you add
so for having this task classifier you
can add additional
on layers after you pre-trained the
model
and depending on what you're interested
in this you can do a classification
entailment similarity multiple choice
questions and so forth
and how that works is essentially they
have this pre-trained transformer here
and they just connect the linear layers
and then it's like a regular classifier
and yeah one thing here is
i won't go into too much detail but it's
how you format the input
if you have a classification you have
like a start token a text
the the sentences and then some
extraction token
and if you have something like um
similarity here
text similarity they have um both texts
and then in flipped order for example so
it just differs a little bit
about how you set up the inputs but yeah
the main
the main thing is that you can just
adopt this pre-trained network
to do whatever you like um in the fine
tuning so this is
really um expensive this is like a
really expensive step that's something
you don't want to do yourself you want
to maybe download this gpt and then
you can on your target data set to the
fine tuning
um yeah and then really what was really
novel about gpd2 and gpt3
is that they actually removed this fine
tuning most language transformers they
use the fine tuning step that i
talked about what gpt2 and gpd3 are
doing though is they tried something new
they were so ambitious that they cannot
remove this fine tuning
and they only have a model now where you
provide
what you want to do as input so for
example if you
want to use their model the gpt2 model
to generate
text what you do is you give it a input
that is
formatted as follows where you say to
the model translate
to french and then you insert your
english text
and then you insert your french text and
it will automatically
figure out what you want to do basically
and you can ask it also different
questions like you give it a sentence
and you can ask
something like um is this object um
so you can say for example um this is a
very nice
sky and is the sky blue and it will it
can generate like an output
that says yes or no or something like
that so it's kind of very um
flexible in terms of what it can do by
only having a certain formatted input
without any fine tuning and
version three i think they kind of went
back a little bit because i think
so here this is called in this context
zero shot learning where they don't have
any examples
of the task the example is in the
descriptions in the task itself they
don't have any training examples
in that sense but i think this was maybe
a little bit too ambitious
so they went back with gpd3 made it a
little bit bigger
and they switched also to few short
learning in this context where in the
future learning
they have at least a few examples of
that task
so just to illustrate how that looks
like so here is this um
zero shot where you have again a prompt
or a task description sorry and then a
prompt and then
it would insert here the french word for
cheese
i honestly don't know any french so i
can't tell you what it is oops
but yeah it would generate this output
here and for the one shot
it's a little bit more i would say
easier for the model because it sees at
least an example
it's not fine-tuned it's just seeing the
example as part of the input
so you have again the task description
here at the top oops
and then you have one example of what
you want to do
and then you have the prompt then few
short learning so if you have let's say
here
um the three short case where you have
one example second example the third
example it becomes easier for the model
uh if you showed at least a few examples
see that's just a note in the chat
i will um maybe answer the questions
after the talk i think almost
over time with a few slides left um
yeah so here
well where was i so yeah here on the
limitation of
the few short tasks though is that you
have a limited sized input
i honestly don't remember what the size
is for gpt3 i think they have some ipis
that i have never used
but let's say for bird models there's a
token
input limitation of 512 tokens it's like
characters or words
not characters but like words or
punctuation
so in that way um you're kind of limited
by what the model can
process as input and how many examples
you provide
so this is actually a fine but i can
imagine it's maybe a challenge if you
have
longer sentences here so that wouldn't
probably work with very long sentences
because then
you fill up all the input with examples
and this yeah this is in contrast to the
fine-tuning approach with
which most other transformers use where
you have an example as part of your
training set that then you
update it with backpropagation like the
gradient update showed another example
and so forth so this is more like a
traditional
way of doing it and yeah the gpd3 model
is very ambitious and i think
i'm not sure if actually the paper is
out yet but yeah this is one of the
latest state-of-the-art models for
generating texts
and another approach is the bird model
which is
a bi-directional encoder so you can
think of gpt more as the decoder which
generates some output whereas
bird is more like the encoder of the
transformer which
ingests like the input and then creates
a representation that you can then use
to train a class specifier on it so gpt
is better
for generating texts bird is better for
classification
so how that works is they have a
pre-training step or they have actually
two different
types of pre-training tasks one is this
masked
language model so what they do is they
mask 15 of the works i like to call it a
marked not masked yet because what they
do is they take these 15 words or 15
of the works if you have a sentence and
then they do different things to it so
here's an example
so let's say this is a sentence here an
input sentence
you would randomly pick 15 of the words
for example
you would pick let's say fox and then
based on these 15
what you do is 80 of the time you
replace this token
the fox with the mask
then uh ten percent of the time you
replace it with a random word for
example
coffee and ten percent of the time you
keep it unchanged
and so this is how you pre-train the
model you have all these sentences and
fifteen percent of the words are
changed in a certain way and the model
has to predict
what the correct word is at a certain
position for example it has
to fill in the right word if there's a
mask or it has to detect
whether this word is right or wrong and
then
sometimes it's unchanged so why would
you have this unchanged
so this is um kind of important for the
model in order to perform
well during inference when you print and
train the model and you want to use it
in the real world
in the real world you usually don't have
masked
sentences and the model here also then
basically learns that sometimes
it should not do anything so in order to
work well or some real text which
doesn't have masks
otherwise it would always expect okay
there are some random
words or masked words so in this way
they found that this performs better if
they have also 10
of the masked or marked words unchanged
and the second pre-training task that
they do at the same time is
next sentence prediction so they have um
a sentence a and a sentence b separated
by a token
and the model has to predict whether
um sentence b indeed follows sentence a
so if you have a text and you reverse
the order of the sentences the model
learns the correct order and this helps
the model yet to work with
inputs that are more than one sentence
so it's essentially classification and
binary classification
is next or is not next essentially
and yeah this classification token is
used as a placeholder
for generating the output because the
number of inputs also matches the number
of outputs
but in word we are not interested in
generating new text we are
essentially interested in classification
so how that works
is just a brief overview of the of
different types of tasks you can do with
bird
so one is sentence pair classification
one is just a single sentence
classification
question answering and single sentence
tagging so here tagging is
for example if you think about um
something like language uh
a grammar software you can label a
sentence by um
what type of like a verb or noun what
type of word
or grammar each word corresponds to but
let's focus maybe only here on the
because we have for the interest of time
on the single sentence classification
task
so you provided an input sentence you
have some embedding here
and then you provide some output
so you have during training you have all
these
tokens so it has to repredict what the
input is given that something is masked
or not
if you have a prediction task you don't
i mean it still generates the sentence
but you don't do anything with it
what you care about is this class label
here so this is why you have this
classification token
this goes then into the class label that
you care about and this is something we
can leverage
for arbitrary classification so i
prepared a code example
for um fine tuning such a bird model for
this
single sentence classification in
pytorch and i should mention it says
single sentence classification and for
the code example
i have this large movie review data set
i mean back then it was large but it's
just
50 000 movie reviews and i think 50
25 000 in the training and 25 000 and
test set
and this is essentially movies or
movie reviews from the imdb movie review
database
and these are multiple sentences so we
can also
use bird for multiple sentences even
though let's say it says
single sentence classification by just
concatenating these sentences
so in that way the only difference is we
don't use this separator token because
the separator token is really more for
comparing two things like this sentence
pair classification so this one can for
example
say whether these sentences are similar
or not like
sentence similarity and things like that
um
yeah so i'm not sure how much uh
time we have i could maybe briefly went
way over
i can maybe briefly show you the code
example it's actually not um
too complicated um i have it on github i
have some annotation
um it's based on a library called
hacking face
it's a very um yeah very very popular
library for
what you probably can't see it now i
have to reshare my screen
okay um let me
see how many slides i have left so we
probably don't have to cover this
let me share my browser screen so you
can briefly see the code example
here i opened it from github
i've also my jupiter lab version which
is maybe better because i can
zoom in here
keyboard so um here
is a notebook for yeah downloading a
pre-trained bird model and fine-tuning
it
on the movie review classification
there's a lot of boilerplate code here
like importing the libraries
some settings for reproducib
reproducibility
downloading the data set um and then
processing it
so here is a pandas data frame of how
the um data set looks like there's like
a text a movie review
and then it's whether it's a positive or
negative
like a binary classification we have 50
000
um combined and here i'm just splitting
them into training
and validation and test sets um then
there's a tokenization step so
tokenization goes from taking the words
and then converting them also
sorry taking the sentence and chopping
it into words
and then um also taking care of
punctuation so punctuation is also
i think on a given token but it really
depends on what type of tokenizer you
use
so there's also a selection of different
tokenizers out there they all
behave a little bit differently but i
recommend if you use
let's say um hugging face i recommend um
finding a tokenizer that matches your
model
i should say we are using here not bert
but the stilbert i think i had a note
about that at the top
yeah the silbert is essentially a
smaller version of bird because um
if you only have let's say one gpu like
uh 1080 ti or
2080 ti like a graphics card with only
11 gigabyte memory
you or i couldn't at least uh load the
whole bird model into memory
or i think i could just barely load it
but then not train it
so there is a version called the
stilbert which is a little bit
smaller so in the stillbirth what they
did is they trained the bird model
and then they removed some weights but
preserving its performance it has
95 of the performance of bird but it's
more lightweight it has 40 percent fewer
uh parameters um
okay so we are using a tokenizer that is
made for this
the stilbert model and um then
encode the data set into tokens
and then i have my data loader here in
pitwatch so this is
a custom data loader here there's
nothing really special about
it if you would build a data loader for
any type of image data set for example
except that we on the way we process
essentially um
encodings so there's like a special um
representation that is i think it's kind
of like a dictionary it's the own python
so yeah a python object or class but it
kind of behaves like a dictionary you
can index into that
and um i will show you how that looks
like so yeah here's an example you can
have a so this is this sorry this will
create a dictionary right
but i think itself it's also some
certain object that contains
uh multiple things
um yeah so here i'm just creating data
loaders from the data set
so this is basically all just set up and
um
here's the main part where we are
loading uh the stillbirth model
and they have multiple models on their
website if you go to the hugging phase
transformer website
and um here this would be for example a
distilbert model
for sentence or sequence classification
you can basically tell based on the
class name
what this is made for and then i'm
loading it on the pre-trained version
and they have also again
i think they have different ones uncased
you would mean it would ignore um
sentence case whether it's
upper or lower case yeah and then i'm
putting the model on my device
putting it into training mode and then
initializing an optimizer
for back propagation this is just a
warning it's uh
i think i don't exactly know what they
want here
uh i think it's just some hints it's
nothing really we have to be concerned
about and here i implemented the
accuracy function
uh to er so what i'm showing you is like
a manual training loop how
basically how you would implement this
in let's say your own pi torch code
and then at the end i will also show you
a trainer class i mean we're almost done
it's just
the last little bit here so
what i have here in this accuracy
function how i write my accuracy
function is usually that i
load the data in batches because um i
usually have large data sets and you
can't just
put the whole data set into the model as
input because you would have them very
large matrix multiplication and then you
run out of
gpu memory so what i usually do is i
like
similar to training i batch up my data
set into chunks
into these batches it's automatically
done by the
data loader here and then i compute
the predicted labels and collect them so
i'm
just collecting the number of correct
predictions and once i have summed up
all the correct predictions
i divide by the number of training
examples so i keep track of the number
of examples
and use that to divide the number of
correct predictions and that gives me
the accuracy so it's in that way not
requiring to load all the data all at
once
and yeah there are some interesting
things here going on so we have
the input ids of the works we have um
the attention mask so the attention mask
is
a little bit weird here why do we need a
detention mask so it's essentially
um for padding so if we have sentences
of different lengths
it will um use zeros to do a padding so
it's essentially denoting which
character is a padding character and
which is an actual word
and then we get our class labels and we
provide
as a model input the input ids the works
so the model itself will then do the
word embedding
and then the attention mask and then we
obtain from the outputs the output is a
kind of i think it's a
an object but it can index into it might
be a dictionary
um so you get the logits which you can
then use um you could use the softmax
function to get probabilities but it's
not necessary because the largest
largest logit is also the largest
probability in softmax so you get the
class label with arc max it's your class
table and then
you know i was just um checking whether
the predicted label
is matching the correct label the actual
label
okay um this is just how i compute the
accuracy
and here is my training loop so i
usually
have a very simple training loop because
when i do research i like to
tinker with things so i like to have
like a more manual approach
and this works similarly i obtain my
input at least from the data loader
if my attention mask labels
compute the outputs here in addition
to to the logits i also need
the loss for optimization so you have to
provide also to the class labels as the
model input
so i get both the logits and the loss
and then
like in regular pi torch i use backward
on the loss
and optimize and this is just for
logging purposes so when i do that on my
data set it
trend for like an hour and get gets like
a 91
accuracy one interesting thing is about
that um briefly i tried on rnn on that
and i think i got like 88
accuracy so using this pre-trained model
even though it's a small data set the
imdb movie review data set even
though it's small i can use a
pre-trained transformer to fine-tune it
on the small data set to get
performance that is actually better than
uh let's say logistic regression which
was like 85 percent
and an rnn which was like 88 and i
didn't do any tuning here by the way i
just used it uh one time because i was
short on time i didn't do any
learning rate tuning nothing so it
worked kind of like out of the box
um and then there's also if you really
want to use transformers seriously i
recommend using um
the apis that hacking phase provides so
they have a trainer class
where you um specify options in
the so-called trainer arguments and then
you have this trainer class where you
provide this as input and it handles
everything automatically
so i also have a run here and actually
it got um
even better performance i think they
have some certain default parameters
for regularization and so forth um so it
was first of all faster
and also the performance was better i
think they have better
better um default options because my
training loop was very minimal
so they have some additional options and
actually um i
for comparison there's a setting um
i only used one gpu when i was um
disabling that one of my computers where
i ran this had a 4gb
was running in 16 minutes so in practice
you maybe also
want to disable that and you get also
way faster training
okay so just briefly sorry sebastian we
have the list
it's to finish please yeah let's
uh sorry i was going way over on time
so yeah maybe let's go yeah we will take
some questions
yes okay you can start asking for
questions please
so your last um thing is i will just go
to my slides for the questions also
sorry that's not the right one
but i am ready for questions now so i
wanted to say i have also way more
detailed um
transformer lecture on youtube from my
deep learning class and
there will be a version of the python
machine learning book coming out
for pytorch which also has a transformer
chapter that will be later this year
so if you want to read more details
about this also this might be a useful
resource
okay yeah so i'm um also i wanted to
mention this the figures here
they are from that chapter so i want to
give also credit to jitin zhao who
helped me a lot with the figures and
yeah writing this chapter
okay so sorry so i think we can take
questions now
no worries hassan you can start using
yeah thank you so much uh
dr space and for this wonderful talk uh
now it's your time about this minute if
you have any questions
uh and you would like uh you'd like to
ask it to the to sebastian
feel free to write it in the chat
or even you can raise your hand and
we'll unmute you so you can ask your
question verbally
so let's start with our first question
for today uh it is from uh
sunny she's asking uh can gbt do
classification
i think so yeah the definitely the first
version i think the other versions can
do
classification too on the hacking way
a web sorry hugging phase website they
have i think also
implementation of gpt a
re-implementation where you can try this
out
i had this uh i remember i have
demonstrated this actually in uh
spring semester in the class um so they
definitely have capabilities to do
classification in gpt two and three
you have to provide it via the context
but in gpt version one
um they also provide
uh classification as an example in the
paper i'm not sure if i had a figure on
this here
but yeah you can but people just because
the way it's trained in this union
direction
way usually uh people agree that bert
type of models would be better for
classification
although you can use rgb2 for
classification
uh another question from marita parvata
is there any use cases right now with
transformers based
vision models out outperform previous
models like
those based on this net and should i use
transformers architecture based models
now to classify images
and replace with yeah that's a good
question so
i um yeah i have seen a lot of papers
recently
are using transformers for computer
vision there's
the classic vision transformer and
they're also newer models
and um i think they
are depends on which paper you read they
are state-of-the-art um compared to on
computer vision models
i think the efficient net version three
paper that came out in april
um showed that they performed better
than computer than transformers but this
was in
april so things might be different now
but one
downside of transformers in computer
vision is that they require
more data for pre-training if you can
get the pre-trade models it might be
for the fine-tuning part it might be
worthwhile but otherwise otherwise i
think it's
more like a research topic now that
people are exploring in practice it's
probably very expensive to train them
i think there's also this paper um i'm
not sure if they compare directly
so efficient net version three was
better than the vision transformer and
there's the halo net paper
that came out in june it's like the
resnet 50 like architecture with
attention
but it's not a vision transform but it
has like resonant-like backbone with
attention
and i think this one outperformed the
fusion at version 3 on imagenet i think
i got like 85 point
something performance um so in that way
i think
yeah it's right now really where
transformers are
i mean they are state-of-the-art but i
think it's still worthwhile using um
cnns for classification for the time
being because they're also yeah cheaper
to train
and then of course we also have
architectures like mlp mixer which is
neither of them it's just uh multi-layer
perceptrons
so yeah it's an interesting time
interesting question i i would say uh
personally i stick with um cnns because
they are easier to train
but in the future who knows so i think
maybe or computer vision transformers
will
take over completely
great uh is also asking is transform
architecture practical for real-world
health tasks
outside of us academia and big tech
companies
and what are the next steps oh sorry
what are the next steps to make
transformer architecture based models
more accessible
with transformers to be able to adapt or
something more
pragmatic we will replace it
yeah good question i think this is one
of the big frustrations that these
transformer models are so big that um as
a private person or an academia it's
really hard to train them
i think um some labs in academia have
large resources for example this um
this paper year um i think the preprint
was
i saw the preprint i think from this
focus people like in 2019
so even two years ago they had the
resources for training that but it must
have been really expensive i think they
had like 50 gpus or
even 50 gpu tpu pots
i think they collaborated with big tech
companies but yeah how do you as a
normal researcher use these i think
yeah i think it's really infeasible to
use these uh
or train pre-trained these models as a
private person i mean you can probably
manage but
you probably need a whole team of
engineers to even set up
all the infrastructure to make this work
and
um in that way i find it more
interesting to really fine-tune these
models like training
or using a pre-trained model and then
just focusing on fine tuning and like
you've seen in this code example i
showed you it's like in
another one hour you can fine tune these
models
but um yeah there are also approaches
where people have made transformers way
more efficient
i haven't covered them here because of
your time constraints but there's for
example
the nice trim former or um i had the
sparse transformer
which um i think yeah they have usually
you have quadratic complexity they have
linear complexity
uh scaling in terms of the input
sequence size so people
have made efforts to make transformers
more efficient well if i
also had a slight even on that here
um there are efforts so this is
unfortunately kept
at or clipped at 2019 here but um here
you can see there's this trend that they
become bigger and bigger and bigger
but there are also some efforts for
example the distiller that i showed you
and other methods that try to reduce the
number of parameters and
allow people to use transformers even
though they may not have
access to large computer infrastructure
but yeah it's like a concern
many people are concerned about there
was also this paper uh calculating the
cost if you have a 1.5 billion parameter
model it costs like 80 to 1000 to 1.6
million just to train this model
so yeah it's we'll see where things go
but yeah this is definitely uh
a concern that this is really unfeasible
for many people
nice we have another question from jason
can dvd took uh be fine-tuned you know
some more data sets like few
hundreds yeah i think so um
personally um i have only used gpk2 via
the hugging phase website where they had
like a
derivative of gpt2 i don't ah i forgot
the name i think it's called gpt
neo so this gpt neo is like an effort by
the open source community to
train a gpt2 model because i don't think
i think maybe has changed but i don't
think they
uh open ai has shared the full model i
think they only provide access uh
through an api
so that way if you only have access to
an api i don't know if you can
fine tune it but there's this gpt neo
project um i can spell it
i would have to search the website i
don't know the top of my head by a
i think it's like this where they have
re-engineered
either gpt version two or three and i
think this might be something that you
could
download and um uh fine tune and i think
hugging face also
has maybe some models i would have to
double check i haven't done this
myself but i think it should be possible
although for gpt 2 and 3 it's kind of
not necessary because you have like
these contexts so they say
with the context it's sufficient but you
could maybe fine tune it i
i i don't know for sure it's a good
question
great all these wondering if you can use
speed train built
for specific domains uh uh like for
example medicine
yeah definitely uh so this is um yeah
yeah so you can definitely um
adopt the architecture for specific
domains so
in that way um if you have a small
medical image data set like texts you
could
technically fine-tune this but if you
have a large data set you can also maybe
um
try to train it from scratch like the
researchers did here
so here instead of training it on
sentences they used the birth model
i think this group there were two groups
that did something similar
they used the bird model and trained it
on amino acid sequences where they had
millions of sequences from the protein
structure database
they were like i mean you can think of
an amino acid sequence as a sentence
but each character there are 20
different amino acids
each character would represent a word
essentially because it's um
it's more like a character level type of
thing but they did that and it worked
well so i can imagine you can also
train it on other types of sequences and
in the medical domain depends on
whether you have a sequence of a
specific domain
specific uh encoding let's say you have
a certain device that outputs certain
values that don't that save a meaning to
a human but that could be passed by a
machine i can also think of a
transformer maybe
being trained on that or if you have
just texts like annotations of
patient records i think that could also
be um done so yeah
you can definitely uh train this on
other things other than um
general text
great uh authy is also asking again
when we find you and between that
would that update the
the vocab of any
the initial vocab will be the same after
fine-tuning vocabulary i think um
a good question so when you fine tune it
so you have the text embedding i think
it would update also the
embedding step i'm this is something i
can't say 100 sure because
when i uh when you use this code from
hugging face
the code from hugging phase includes the
encoding as far as i know because you
only provide the input ids of the words
and then coding is part of the model and
if you update this i
i think you should also it should also
update the
embeddings i'm like 90 sure but not 100
because um yeah i haven't really looked
um at the code line by line maybe they
have a line that
freezes the weights for the embeddings
so that i don't know for sure but i
suspect
the minutes are also updated
sorry i think the question might have
been about the vocabulary size
so i think the vocabulary size is um
fixed so i don't think this can be
updated because the vocabulary size
depends on the
um input id on the tokenizer so if i
think if you
have i think a tokenizer would remove
words from your input text that is not
included in the pre-training so if you
have some arbitrary words
that are not in the database where the
model was
pre-trained on i think you don't have to
worry about it if you use the right
tokenizer because it would replace it by
an arbitrary token but of course
also the model wouldn't then be able to
perform well on
if you have a lot of different um tokens
because these are tokens the model has
never seen before and they are all
i think converted to a arbitrary um
unknown token or something like that
okay nice uh all to do do you want to
say
uh anything uh
you can and solve and ask any questions
can you hear me
yes yes sure thank you sorry for uh
insisting on this on this question but
uh i just wanted to do to
to return a bit to this point or to the
last one to the vocabulary one
my my idea is that of a fast ai library
in which they have the nlp part of it
together with the image and actually
they uh jeremy howard has made this
this uh library in a way then when you
fight you
fine-tune the the pre-trained model
to a specific domain then all the words
that are not
tokens that are not part of the uh
original vocabulary of the pre-trained
model
will be added oh to the new vocabulary
and that will be they will train by like
starting from from scratch let's say you
know
like as you do with the pre-training but
with this
but i'm not sure that this is the case
for bert to be honest because i've been
asking the guys
in some other talks like this and as far
as i know they don't do that and that is
the the original question like how well
does perform birth
pre-trained let's say pre-trained birth
when we fine-tune it i don't know it
matters anyone most of the characters i
don't know in
whatever other domain specific uh task
when most of the words or tokens are
right
tokens might be quite different and they
will be just unknown no
it's like technical questions sorry
about that yes
party you you answered thank you but
just like it's not about the the size of
the
vocabulary but like exactly this thing
thank you so much
yeah um so yeah i think um
that's a good point i think they are
kind of related um so i think
in the birth model they
basically have a fixed vocabulary where
all the words
appear that appear during pre-training
plus an unknown token
and then if you have doing fine tuning
the new words it will just be mapped to
this unknown token so they don't expense
exactly uh vocabulary
right that's what i'm suspecting and you
mentioned that
fast ai um they would add it to um yeah
yeah i haven't uh really worked with the
fast ai
version of this so that sounds like a
good approach right now if you then
have some really if you don't want to
maybe retrain it completely from scratch
but you have a very different data set
with different
tokens so you you kind of um it's kind
of more flexible in that way i would say
yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah thank you anyway
thank you uh alti again if you want to
ask any questions uh
you can raise your hand and we will
animate you so we can ask questions so
dr sebastian
back to chat we have a question from
anna
how to handle the bottleneck caused by
data loader reading each example from
memory
um yeah the bottleneck oh um so
in terms of speed um yeah you could
increase uh
so what i do sometimes if it's too slow
if i have a very large data set what i
would do is i would increase
the i would make a new data loader um
for the training set
if i want to compute the training set
accuracy i would have a second one
which has just a larger batch size than
the one i used during training and for
the test set
i would just um set the batch size
really large
as large as it goes until it crashes
because um
at some point it would just crash but in
a case like this
i would say it's not really a bottleneck
it's um i mean it takes maybe under a
minute or maybe a few seconds to process
the whole data set in each
epoch and we are only computing in the
accuracy function
um like
the performance in each epoch so it's
not like um
too often i think this is reasonable but
maybe the question is also about like
how we deal with that bottleneck during
training
that's a good question i um actually
yeah that's one limitation so i could
only go up to batch size 16 here in this
example
because otherwise i would run out of
memory so one way to deal with that
would be
choosing a different type of transformer
for example so there are um
more efficient transformers that have
fewer parameters and smaller maybe um
inputs sizes or smaller number of tokens
that might be an impossibility
but there are also different ways for
distributed computing it depends on
what type of distributed computing you
do some can kind of
put the model onto different devices and
handle
with handle batch batches like that so
for instance if you remove
the number of gpu restrictions i had in
my code it would run on multiple gpus
and i think it splits up the batch size
um
you know in this case it i think would
multiply the batch size if you have 4
gpus by 4 and then each gpu gets 16 but
still
you're processing 64 um training
examples at the same time and then
you average the gradients from the
different gpus in that way
you can use larger batch sizes if you
have multiple gpus that's another option
but yeah it's fundamentally a limitation
of matrix multiplication
in memory for example if you have um
only access to one gpu that could be
challenging
great uh we're still with anna uh she's
asking
uh how can an individual like graduate
student train at
a transformer for data for which there
is not a pre-trained transformer
available
is it even possible resource wise
um yeah a good question i haven't done
this myself yet i'm
i think based on what i've seen from
papers where people have done that for
example this protein sequence paper
trading from scratch looked very scary
in terms of what resources um
they had to use in order to make that
happen and if
the only case is like maybe if you have
a small data set um maybe that might be
feasible but i think then maybe the
transformer won't be the best option if
you only have a small data set for
pre-training
then maybe using a classic rnn or
even a back-of-works model might be a
better approach but yeah i don't have
unfortunately a good answer for that i
think
that's a concern i have too if you i
personally also don't have
access to a large cluster where i could
do that and even if i would have access
to that i think um
all the engineering efforts that go into
setting this up is also
kind of challenging so companies so far
as i know have really
large teams of engineers that only
really focus on the coding part just to
run the model on these
multiple devices and gpus i mean there
are apis that make that simpler but i
think in practice it's still not very
easy to do that so you need to have like
experts
doing that but maybe i'm wrong so i
don't want to discourage anyone from
trying this out in practice but um i
don't have a better answer at that
moment
nice back to richard palata
i have a personally fine-tuned a
pre-trained gbt-2
model which has uh 117 million
parameters
with about 2600 mid-sized
text on 70 lines each
and talk with me 15 minutes and
i think yeah that's nice okay
so on a very small uh 3 000 data point
okay
i didn't expect it to perform that well
that is actually cool so
uh 1.7 million it will be the size of
gpt-1 approximately that is impressive i
i think that that sounds very promising
then
so forget what i said in the previous
answer uh maybe it is possible to really
pre-train them on a small data set so
yeah great
a question from sujana why is leia norm
used and not much no
uh that is a good question why is layer
gnome used and not
batched on i think it has something to
do with the fact that
um we have a sequence um
so you normalize across the sequence and
not across
um across the batches but i
um top of my head i don't have a good
answer i could uh
i think i was thinking about that at
some point but i
forgot i think it's the way we normalize
over
over the batches in a way it's a good
question
another thing is bathroom doesn't really
perform well if you have
batch sizes smaller than 32 or 16 but i
don't think this is the answer i think
the answer is
more about um the way we normalize this
i would have to
think about this again while you know
and not batch known
a good question
[Music]
great i think this concludes uh the q a
session
for this talk uh thank you so much uh dr
sebastian
uh back to you off now ah thank you
hassan thank you dr sebastian
um sebastian can you share the slides or
the code
that you show us on the chat so we can
post it on the twitter yep
let me do it right away um i have this
github repository here and
the github repository has a link to the
slides
i can also post it separately
it's right here well thank you uh great
so we definitely want to give a huge
thank you for you sebastian
uh this was super insightful and hopeful
and um thank you everyone for joining
and please follow us on twitter for more
details about upcoming talks
and see you soon thank you yeah thank
you so much everyone for attending and
also very good questions
sorry for rushing a little bit about or
through the topics i
i don't know it's like i always want to
talk about so many things and there's
only so little time
but i appreciate your patience and
joining me here today that was
fun and i really liked your questions it
was cool all right yeah then have a
great rest of the day everyone bye bye
bye bye
you